[Music]
this morning putting the rabbits in the
hat it's the memoir of longtime actor
brian cox who's achieved a new level of
fame 50 years into his career the title
comes from cox's belief that if the
stage isn't set properly whatever comes
next won't be either
he would know after spending decades as
a leading man on stage in england he
moved to america for the second phase of
his life excelling as a character actor
in movies like manhunter
rob roy and the cult classic super
troopers
but it's his latest role as logan roy on
the hbo series succession that has
turned him into a household name
which one of you boys did it tom
yes sit on the floor
it's fun
seriously yeah it's a game boar on the
floor succession is all about who comes
next in the family business
but right now no one watching wants him
to leave
his guest of honor brian cox has
devoured the role of media magnate's
logan roy the last piggy
to eat a sausage is the mole a character
who tries in his own unique way to
prepare the next generation
in real life
cox's dad
never got the chance i was a shock a
hell of a shock i mean my
you know he went away one day and he was
gone i mean he died within three weeks
of his diagnosis
cox was only eight years old when his
father died of cancer i was distressed
of course you know because he was my
daddy
i was very distressed
they didn't want me to go to the funeral
so they put me in front of the
television
and
i sat that whole afternoon watching tv
do you regret that they didn't want you
to go no i i don't regret it actually
because television is a great comforter
to me so i i associate television with
comfort and
and solving me in some kind of way after
his dad's passing the family was left
destitute and cox's mother suffered
through mental illness and shock therapy
left independent far too early he writes
in his memoir that he found inspiration
on the screen
including from a late great british
actor i was 14 and there was this film
called saturday night and sunday morning
which had been a big success and this
actor called albert finney bring out
your dead on cedar oh it's you there
come on in love where's the tribe
[ __ ]
and i took myself to the plaza cinema
walked in and i just saw him on the
screen and i thought
oh thank
god
i can do it is possible because this guy
clearly does it and he was astonishing
you know he without albert a lot of us
would not exist scotland will always be
home this is home now too yeah let's
become home i'm i'm peripatetic you know
home is where the work is for more than
three decades his work was on the stages
of england where cox was the
quintessential leading man
until he made the move
to hollywood movies i want you to help
me dr lecter
the original hannibal lecter in
manhunter you want to know how he's
choosing them don't you brave hearts it
was the same for me and your daddy
when our father was killed
the jason bourne films do you hear me
he's still out there now get him get
jason
and churchill just to name a few
the passage of the sea has been made
with far less loss than we apprehended
then in 2018 succession creator jesse
armstrong gave cox at age 72
what may be the role of a lifetime
logan roy go okay me both of you one who
fixes it
gets a cookie logan and i have one thing
in common
we are very disenchanted with the human
experiment
the difference is i'm an optimist and
logan is a pessimist and he's a
misanthrope i'm not a misanthrope
because my job is to understand and
really like humanity you say he he does
villainous things but he's not a villain
what does that mean
i don't think he's a villain i think
he's he's as human as the rest of us but
he has incredible shortcomings three
years ago you were still in the nut
house dad it's called rehab
and i'm in recovery you know the key to
logan is that
as jesse said to me very early on
because i was saying
the first question i asked was does he
love his children
this man who behaves so extraordinary
that's the point he loves his children
and once you have that once you know
that that's what logan is
then
it's what's happening is incredibly
painful and incredibly difficult for
logan though he doesn't go anywhere near
there i'm stuck in quicksand my family
disappeared the world is wobbling here
that's why it's a beautifully written
character and it's full of mystery so we
don't always know what's going on which
i love i love that aspect so the
audience are not being fed stuff they're
having to just
make assumptions and sometimes the
audience make the wrong assumption
because those kids can be right pens in
the ass
you think
you think
all he's trying to do is find his
success and put his business that's all
the guys trying to do all right all
right let's get started equally as
extensive as cox's list of film and
stage roles he's one of the worst
students we've got
his political and personal commentary
you come out of this book swinging with
a story about steven seagal yeah
not a fan
well
no that's not true
that is true well yeah wait a minute no
ostensibly not a fan i mean he's not an
actor good god i mean i felt i do have
sympathy for stephen because he's a
buddhist with an ulcer you know
and i do have sympathy for him actually
because i just felt there was some
there's something neglected about him
well there's a long list of actors who
you comment on yeah
i won't name it a long list it's a it's
a reasonably brief phrase
believe you me that the list could be a
hell of a lot longer
you wear your politics often on your
sleeve it's only a good place to wear
them
sure i think a lot of it is fighting for
middle class folks working class folks
who may have been overlooked
well if you come from a feudal system
which is what i do i mean my country is
feudal this was the great attraction for
me of america i mean not just the the
work direction but the idea and
unfortunately it's somewhat missing
is the egalitarian idea that this is
supposedly an egalitarian society and
that was the attraction for me because i
was the voice of blair i was the voice
of labor in the 97 election and that was
the most exciting time of my life and
then i saw what happened in iraq
weapons of mass destruction which didn't
exist it's just crazy what we've done
and irresponsible it's totally
irresponsible and blair i saw blair on a
program saying oh i didn't know what the
effects would be well then you're not
thinking properly man
anyway don't give me a night i get hot
in the color it's such a difficult to
get you exercise
yeah it is
but it's good to be exercised i mean i'm
at least i'm not a bland old man no you
are not
no he ain't far from it he's got fire in
his belly yeah and he likes all the time
we had a great conversation and some of
the stories about his days in theaters
decades in theater are really wonderful
in the book there's so much we couldn't
put in here he's actually adding an
addendum
to when the paper the next version comes
out of the book so we can put even some
more of this in context when he talks
about not more
the actors
[Laughter]
he's not afraid to talk about at all